自分と共に歩んでる人たちに苦労をかけて
いる自分が辛かっただから途中で辞めて
しまった社員もいっぱいいるのでごめんね
とあらゆる逆境には必ずそれと同等かいや
それ以上の成功の種が隠されている青木サ
の人生経営哲学100回聞いたら豊かに
なる
話今日の質問は非常にシンプルなんですが
これまで経営をしていて1番辛かったこと
は何ですかまたそのことをどのように
乗り越えましたかというご質問ですこの方
経営者の方
[音楽]
ですま正直俺大好物なんだよねその辛い
ことがうんだからあんまりないんだよね
ぶっちゃけたこと言うとなんだろうなて
いうのはいいことばっかりあるというのが
ありえないでしょうチャレンジしたら当然
つまづくリスクもあるわけだし
まあ正直振り返ったら全部キャリアって
いう言葉で終わっちゃうんだけどでも
あえて言うならやっぱりそれは
1990年に僕は横綱千富士の引退記念の
プログラムをま発売したわけだよねこれ
全く売れなかったんですよいいプログラム
だったんだけれどもその時にやっぱり苦労
をかけたってのは辛いよね
うちの家内もそうだしま専務だったから
あと当時の社員に対しても高い報酬を払え
なかったよね申し訳ないなと思ってるよ
払いたかったんだよでも払えないのよもう
毎月300万400万の決済それはま僕
自身はなんて言うのかなある意味では
チャレンジして必死にそれを乗り越えて
いく目の前のことにしてま元々トップセル
トップマネージャーというかその営業
上がりなので仕事がハードドっていうのは
全然辛くないんだけどま正直やっぱり家内
が例えばお金の面でね苦労してる姿社会
保険労務事務所にお金を払えなくて待って
もらってそして先付けこぎってをく
れっていうのよ厳しいんだよ社会保険ロム
事務所ねいやだからまある意味で自分の
ことがで辛いんじゃなくて自分と共に歩ん
でる人たちに苦労をかけたっていうか苦労
をかけている自分が辛かったそれが1番か
なまあは離職だよなぶっちゃけやっぱりさ
俺は振ったことないけど振られまくってき
たからさで最初の頃なんかも変な自己啓発
セミナー会社みたいに言われたわけじゃん
でもそれはしょうがないよね千の富の引退
記念のプログラムとさ当時私はアメリカで
デイタイマーという会社の公認のタイム
マネージメントスペシャリストの資格を
取ってその千富のプログラムと手帳を
くっつけて目標達成の研修プログラムそれ
が頂点の道講座って頂点の道って大体その
プログラムから来たわけでワオ接中みたい
なプログラムであとは私がトレーニング
能力がめちゃ高かったのでというのは前職
ねま独立前のお世話になったコンサル会社
ま研修系の能力開発のコンサル会社です
けれども当時世界で最も優秀な
コンサルタントと言われたブライアン
トレーシーというねアメリカの
コンサルタントの日本と台湾の権利を持っ
ている会社で僕はまチーフトレーナーやっ
てたのでその前はブリタニカでセールス
マネージャーでトレーニングやってるわけ
だトレーナーとしてのキャリアは
ものすごく積んでるわけだよねただ資本金
500万社員5名でスタートした会社で
まだ10名足らずの時にそういうね
メーカー目指して商品作ったでもそれが
もう本当に売れなくて1億5000万の
在庫になってでも今考えたらあの時が1番
自分が成長しているだからあらゆる逆境に
は必ずそれと同等かいやそれ以上のの種が
隠されているこれは私の確信ですねうんだ
から振り返ればあれがあるから今がある
わけで今アチーブメントはま売上66億
経常利益が21億というねまこの
アチーブメント
グループ3者の自己資本率もず高くなって
日本テレビ放送網さんにも信頼をいだいて
株主にもなってもらってたりそういう意味
ではやっぱり1つのハードルを超えてると
思うんだよねま経団連にも入ってるし経済
同友会東京商工会議所8万5社の中の76
社の第1号銀企業にもなってるから今は胸
を晴れますよグレートプレスワークスも準
グランプリ2年連続9年連続働きが
アワードでベストカンパニーもなってるし
ま平均賃金も630まぐらいになってます
からね220人の新卒まで入れて今
ちょうどその600万を超える平均年収に
なってるっていうことは決して悪い会社で
はないと思うんだけどでも僕が目指してる
ものはもうちょっと上があるんですよ
こんなもんじゃないんだよでここが
ものすごく大事なところでそんな心ざしの
高い僕が5年も6年も経済的に大変な時代
があったわけよいやそれをだから最も身近
な人を僕は大事にするのが元の私が最も
身近な人に苦労をかけたその後はその恩に
報いる社員に対しても今もそうだしだから
途中でやめてしまった社員もいっぱいいる
のでごめんねと今の俺だったら解消がある
からやめないで済んだだろうなとだって
そんな状態の中で毎月毎月300万
400万返済するわけだからさブラック
企業ぐらい働いせよブラックってよりも
こないだのYouTubeでも言ったけど
ウルトラブラックってよりもプラチナ
ブラックとかなんかもうどう表現していい
かだって16時間ぐらい発からね俺はそれ
はだって1回も銀行の返済遅れたことない
し給料の支配も1回もないし当たり前の
ことなんだけどでもその当たり前のことを
当たり前にやりきるって簡単じゃないんだ
よ社会保険労務事務所だけですようんあの
社会保険料だけはちょっと待ってもらった
それ以外はもうどんなことも僕は約束守り
してきたから僕あの早くから社会出てるの
で金の信用はやっぱり守らないと後ろが
ないんですよだからやっぱり信用だけは
本当に大事にしてきたねあとはリアル
ゲームだよ楽しいよ俺経営楽しいと思っ
てる本当に能力発好きだから能力発が好
きっっていうことは逆境を味わうんですよ
でも身近な人は迷惑じゃんそうでしょ
身近な人は迷惑ですよ本当ごめんなさいと
今も思ってますやめてたね子も本当に
ごめんねって特に新卒で最初の2005年
の入った16人のうち今残ってるの1人
じゃん2006年のもう16人入って今
橋本拓也ま取締り役なってるけど1人だよ
ね2007年で高橋や取締り役なってる
あとはもうすごい拠点長もそれからもう
重要なポジションにいっぱいついてるけど
それでもやっぱり18人ぐらい入ったのか
なあの時なそれでもうん残ってんの67人
6人ぐらいでしょ67人だと思うよてこと
は今の会社だったらもっと手厚くして
あげれるかな俺ずっとそう思ってんだよ神
様もっと俺に解消のある人間にしてほしい
もっと社員を本当豊かにしたいやっぱり
自分が貧乏な家庭にったから家族や社員は
貧しくさせたくないわけ
よだからごめんねというまた思い出すとさ
ちょっと悲しくなるぐらい辛い時期が56
年ありましたこれ話すと3日ぐらいかかる
やねうんそんな
[音楽]
感じどんな問題も乗り越えてきたことは
逃げなかったってことだよなそして
やっぱり成功哲学それからまバイブル
そして選択理論
ここにある書いてあることを生きたって
ことですよ概念じゃなくてやっぱり信念は
現実を決定するまそして事実今ね同じ
苦しい時期を共に歩んできた人たちを今
豊かにはできてると思っているのでもっと
頑張りますまそれが私の今の質問に対する
答えかな人はねいい時ばっかりじゃないの
で葛藤の海を泳ぎ渡る力が必要なので是非
ねその力を身につけてもらいたいなと思い
ますまよかったらね私の研修にもね本当に
3日間の研修まだまだあと数年はやります
ので是非ね来ていただければと思います
経営者の方特に辛い時って色々あるんだよ
でもそれがね振り返ると自分を強くして
ますよ頑張って欲しいと思います是非
コメント欄にもコメントお願いします
チャンネル登録高評価よろしくお願いし
ます
[音楽]
今日ちょうどあのファーストリティリング
が初任休が来年4月からあの33万になる
というニュースで10%像っていうのが
ニュースになってたんですけどよく考えて
みるとあの私入社した4年前は初任休
25万だったんでで次の4月33万じゃ
ないですかうちもそうするともう33%
ぐらい上がってるのでこの4年で33%
増加させた会社は日本探してもあまりない
んじゃないかなっていうのはそうだろ思い
ますけどね
プライドプライドだよ会社はね大きさじゃ
ないよ小さくてもねそこの経営者がねどれ
だけ社員を愛し具体的に物心共に豊かに
できるかだよそこをチャレンジしなきゃ
だめうんもうケチはだめもうケチなんだ
から大体世の中の経者俺もたくさん見てき
たけどほとケチやが多いよいやこれ前まだ
ぶっちゃけたこと言っちゃったけどいやだ
からねなんだろうなその僕は自分が貧しい
家庭に育ったから自分がやっぱり豊かにな
るっていうことを頑張ってきたってことは
社員にもやっぱり豊かにしてあげたい
とうん自分がされて嫌なことは人にもし
ないと同じように何事でも人々からして
欲しいと望むことを他の人々にもそのよう
にせよとバイブルにあるわけだよそれやっ
てたら絶対豊かになると思うよ気がつい
たらアチーブメントっていう会社自体もね
経常利益は20億でしょ俺実際これある
専門の期間が調べたら会社そのものは
200億ぐらいの価値があるってわけだ
から
ねま僕は次のステージでこれやっぱり上場
させていこうと思ってるしそして社員にも
持ち株でともかく俺はともかく僕を信じて
ついてきた人間はみんな豊かにします
そして死んできますたったそれだけです
あとどこにも正しさもないしうんもうそれ
が俺の今の頑張る理由だから社員可愛い
もん可愛いうんだからあのいろんななんか
ねコンサル会社いろんな会社あるけどね人
を大事にすることを進めないコンサル会社
はねコト猿は担当いるのね部類ですだめ人
を大切にできない経営はろな経営じゃない
んだ
よなんでそんなコンサルタントの言うこと
聞くかっていうと経営者自身がね例えばね
自分がきつく言えないからコンサル会社に
通してきつく言わせるとかそれから
やっぱりね利己的なんだってだから安い
給料でコキ使おうとするわけよそり離職
当たり前でしょ俺だってやめちゃうよ
ぶっちゃけそんなんだったらだから
やっぱりね経営者自身の心のあり方やり方
じゃないんだよ僕あの大学でねま私は今
大学で成功哲学教えてるけど3つの大学で
ね客員教授ででも大学の経学学んだ人は
みんな経営は利潤の追求だっっていうから
その利潤を追求していく中で人をコストと
扱うんだよこれが問題なんです人は
インベストメントです
ね英語もできないのに力強く英語言っ
ちゃったよ投資です投資だ教育も投資じゃ
ん人も投資全部投資です投資してる会社は
大きくなるまだからうちなんかも初人休
33万だもんなプライドだプライドうん
なんか1曲歌いたくなっちゃったプライド